[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now have you
ever wondered
what being part of a clinical trial is
all about excel clinical research tells
us more take a look
[Music]
a clinical trial is a research study
that is conducted by excel clinical
research
and we are investigating
a drug or medication for fda approval
so why would someone come in to enroll
into a clinical trial
one common reason is that it's an
alternative
treatment not available not yet
available
or not yet approved by the fda so
for example if you had liver cancer
there is a pharmaceutical company that's
developed a medication that could cure
your liver cancer but it's not fda
approved yet
it goes through a clinical trial to
assess the
safety of the medication and efficacy
of the drug so that would be an
alternative treatment available to to
you
to see if that will benefit your medical
condition
xcel clinical research does studies on
the flu virus the coronavirus as well as
various studies on eczema eczema is a
skin disorder found on a lot of
people especially people of color
it's a it's almost a rash that you find
on the skin
it's itchy it's red it includes
dryness and sometimes open wounds
we are looking for patients that have
moderate to severe
eczema that qualify and at least 10
percent of their body
usually our patients don't experience
very many side effects
with the eczema study we have seen a
side effect of
a headache but that can be relieved with
tylenol
so for um in order to be eligible for
the coronavirus study you do have to
have
coronavirus you could either be having
symptoms or you
could be present with no symptoms um the
length of that study
is approximately 169 days with as little
as
four visits here on site another study
that we do have going on here at excel
is the vaccine
study for coronavirus as well it's more
of a preventative
study so we don't want you to have
coronavirus we're also doing a study
with
influenza or flu as well because
not only do we have coronavirus but
we're also having flu season that is
here as well
so we do want to be able to give
patients treatment options for the flu
when you enroll into a clinical trial
you do receive
a patient stipend or compensation
for your time and participation and
travel you do not need to have a
referral from your physician
we do accept referrals from your
physician but
you are welcome to call excel clinical
research
and we will explain to you all the
criteria
required in order to make sure you're
healthy enough to enroll into a clinical
trial
excel clinical research is located on
south maryland parkway you can find them
online
at vegasstudy.com or call them at
702-553-1236
las vegas now we'll be right back